a law under consideration in
Pennsylvania could give victims of child
sexual abuse a second chance at justice
groundbreaking Pennsylvania grand jury
report this month revealed the Catholic
Church's alleged cover-up of decades of
sexual abuse by 301 priests as we've
reported investigators found disturbing
allegations involving more than a
thousand abused children in one example
five sisters and one family were abused
by the same priest one of the children
was just 18 months old
the Pennsylvania Catholic Conference
told CBS News in a statement quote we
are devastated and outraged outraged by
the revelations of terrible sexual abuse
crimes committed in the Catholic Church
the time to discuss legislation will
come later our focus now is on improving
ways that survivors and their families
can recover Pennsylvania Attorney
General Josh Shapiro led the
investigation and is with us now good
morning good morning I know that the
grand jury also found evidence against
more than 400 priests why could you only
charge two of them we have weak laws in
Pennsylvania which only allowed me to
charge two priests in in part because
our statute of limitations is it's
called is so short but because of the
sophisticated cover-up because of the
efforts that went by with through the
bishops stretching all the way up to the
Vatican they shielded these predator
priests from the arm of the law we
charged to one has already pled guilty
and this priest went from being a priest
to a known sexual predator our community
and the other priests will be going to
court later this fall your office has
done incredible work but it is sickening
to read this report and what you guys
uncovered since it was released how many
people have called your office in dorms
of reporting perhaps additional abuse
nor we set up a special clergy abuse
hotline we've received as of late last
night 733 calls to our clergy abuse
hotline in just the nearly two weeks
since this report came out I want every
single survivor out there to know and
and CBS has done an unbelievable job
giving voice to these survivors through
your coverage every survivor should know
if they call our hotline we will listen
and we will
and we will does the cover-up continue
by the Catholic Church I believe that
statements made by bishops in
Pennsylvania by Cardinal Wuerl
specifically to deny this does further
the cover it covers up the cover-up and
the church's own documents Nora improve
that they are not telling you everyone
in the way you you've actually said that
this goes all the way to the Vatican
this cover-up yes so there are specific
examples where when the abuse occurred
the priests would go the bishops would
go and lie to parishioners lie to
law-enforcement lie to the public but
then document all of the abuse in secret
archives that they would share
oftentimes with the Vatican there are
specific examples where the Vatican knew
of this abuse and they were involved in
the cover-up what are you talking about
here is a structure of cover-up it's not
just some hurried measures that there
was an actual organized way of covering
up which suggests there are 49 other
states are you getting calls from other
states and is it your assumption that
this was going on in lots of other
parishes across the country I think
Pennsylvania is pretty unique but I
don't think unfortunately we're unique
in this way and yes I have received
calls from more than a dozen attorneys
general of both parties from across the
country as well as receiving a call from
a representative of the Department of
Justice some of them have opened
investigations others have inquired as
to how they should investigate but
unfortunately I think what we saw in
Pennsylvania the widespread sexual abuse
of children
the organized sophisticated cover-up
unfortunately is probably not unique to
Pennsylvania it go all the way up to the
Pope I know that it stretches to the
Vatican look I'm a prosecutor I deal in
facts and evidence and apply the law and
I can tell you that there is facts there
is evidence that takes this cover-up and
what occurred in Pennsylvania directly
to the Vatican when Nicky first brought
it to us it really is stomach-turning
Josh you know most of us can say that's
horrible but there's nothing we can do
about it
but you're in a position to do something
about it it's so hard to believe that
some of these priests will now actually
get away with it what do you want to see
happen I want to see happen what the 23
grand jurors in Pennsylvania who spent
too
years listening to this gut-wrenching
testimony reading the secret archives
contained in the church's records just
feet away from where the bishops it I
want to see the grand juries
recommendations past look Gill there
should be no statute of limitations when
it comes to the sexual abuse of a child
right now we're limited in that
timeframe about 40 other states have
already done away with the statute of
limitations we should do that we should
give victims the opportunity as the
grand jury calls for to go in and get
aid to help them with their counseling
these grand jury report recommendations
need to pass and I'm putting every ounce
of my being the survivors are putting
every ounce in their being to seeing it
pass in pensively ninety nine of the
priests were from Pittsburgh the Asia
diocese thank you the pittsburgh diocese
it's bishop David zubik denies there was
a cover-up in a statement saying the
Diocese of Pittsburgh today is not the
church that is described in the grand
jury report you believe that's true two
responses to Bishop zubik number one
he's not telling the truth and the
church's own documents prove that and
second Nora child rape in 1970 he's the
same as child rape in 2018 it is
unacceptable and the idea that the
bishop would just simply say oh well
this was a long time ago
he's demonstrably false and it is
absolutely the wrong response to this
yeah we're gonna have to leave it with
those very strong words thank you very
much for joining us Josh you're watching
CBS we'll be right back
[Music]